the skeleton coast in northwestern
namibia is home to brown hyenas also
known as strand wolves
are very important in the ecosystem and
they've got a very important role to
play but they portrayed as
the bad guys and that's what people
think about hyenas in general
we are forever
killing our coach yet our entire card
open we can do nothing about it but if
the farmers come up and say we are
killing now we are digging our own hands
i understand they happen
we're now living in a nature reserve
alongside wild animals we can earn as
much with them now as we do with goats
and sheep so i no longer shoot them
the hyenas are perfectly adapted to the
extreme desert conditions and icy called
ocean current
biologist m z fever has been studying
the animals here for seven years and is
still fascinated by them
she's a science coordinator for a
tourism company that supports
conservation projects in the region
i've got a lot of respect for arenas
because to survive as a large scavenger
in the desert it's it's no mean feat um
and they're also very social
when they're out there they solitary so
you just see these single aina's out
there but when they back at the den when
there are
cubs at the den there's a lot of social
going on there's a lot of time spent
with the cups playing with the cups
grooming the cups
fairvae discovered a network of dens off
the coast where packs of sand wolves
gather to socialize and share their
catch
they carry carcasses dozens of
kilometers through the desert to feed to
their cubs in the dens
scavenger animals like these prevent
diseases from spreading making them
important for livestock farming
but their reputation as predators means
they're mercilessly hunted
[Music]
people would put out poison for lions
for leopards cheetahs and in the hyenas
would be bycatch of that just people are
afraid of hyenas so people don't
appreciate the value of brown eye in us
and they scare off the hyenas so people
would would throw stones at them they
would chase them with cars
seven years of drought have ravaged the
region
the animals here have to travel ever
greater distances in search of food
this means they cross paths with farmers
like emmanuel gurirab who are now losing
more and more livestock to predators
issue today
the incident took place at farm leop in
the canada region last week where two
lions killed 66 goats and ten sheep
belonging to farmer emmanuel called up
as a result of the lion attack gurirab
lost half of his herd a sizable
financial loss for the farmer
[Music]
the government compensates farmers after
such incidents but at a rate around half
of market value
the wild animals from the desert the
lions the elephants causes a lot of
problems
we don't gain anything from having wild
animals here they bring us nothing
our livestock are our income how we earn
our living
near his stall guri rob has discovered
fresh hyena tracks
brown hyenas don't hunt goats but the
tracks could have been made by spotted
hyenas a more aggressive species
if the government doesn't take care of
the hyenas we have no choice
we have to shoot them
that's the plan
[Music]
when he was a cattle herder phineus
casaona also killed hyenas and lions
today he protects them
he's a ranger and member of the anub
community reserve
since the 90s farmers like casaona have
joined neighbors to create their own
nature reserves which now cover about
one-fifth of namibia's land mass
last night elephants raided a neighbor's
vegetable patch
so for the next few nights casaona will
stand guard
despite the problems they cause the
farmers still want to protect the
animals
things have changed
back in the day if a hyena took one of
your animals you hunted it down and
killed it
today we live in a new world with laws
that protect wild animals
farmers have agreed on limiting
livestock so that both wild and farm
animals can coexist
since antelope populations increased
attacks by wild predators have gone down
anab earns its income from tourism and
was able to install electricity and
water connections and rebuild a
preschool
back on the skeleton coast a ranger
informs fairvae that an elephant calf is
missing the biologist fears the worst
she finds the calf halfway to a watering
hole
due to the ongoing drought the mother
couldn't lactate
there is no hope for the young elephant
[Music]
it's part of life out here i mean
everyone dies you live
but she was born yesterday
so it seems such a waste for
not to have a life
not here
[Music]
yeah so i love all animals
and you do what you can
but eventually
[Music]
life must get on and this is this is
part of a day
this is part of life
long periods of drought have made the
fight for survival even harder here
hyenas and other animals must search for
new living environments
but with the help of researchers like
mse fairvae and community-based
conservation efforts there's still a
chance in namibia for people and animals
to re-adapt and forge a life out of the
desert
[Music]
you